one of the chapters that really
intrigued me was from your book was a
red flags chapter um it talks everything
from
personality to life decisions to
physical
appearances and things that they've done
to
affect their physical appearances you
know from tattoos um excessive piercings
um
you know it's 20 it's 20 things but um
without going into the details of all of
it um
do you believe that the biggest one out
of all these is the inability to
acknowledge
their issues
and
work on improving them
considering that all those things are
present or not i believe that a person's
biggest red flag biggest toxic trait
is without a doubt in my own personal
experience is
the inability to recognize their own
faults the inability to recognize their
own mistakes their inability to
acknowledge
their contribution to the problems
in their interpersonal relationships
regardless of their relationship with
you they're relationships what they're
what they're what they're what did i say
earlier about the first step in
unplugging
um
understanding dynamics
oh recognizing
so the first step in unplugging is
recognizing your own
and
most
i mean let's deal with it from the
female perspective because i mean the
chapters written i mean the book's
written for guys you know let's just be
honest and the chapter is written about
you know
these red flags that you should be aware
of and you know by the way all of these
red flags that i mentioned in the
chapter come from well over a thousand
consults with with guys and just note
taking
what it was that was the catalyst and
the problem that they're dealing with
right because i always say guys are
um masters of complicating their lives
and then justifying why they do it and
looking past a red flag is a really bad
move on a guy's part and you can you
know you can date these women you can
date a woman with all 20 of these red
flags you can marry them you can put
babies in them you can do all that stuff
but i'm going to tell you right now if
you ignore those red flags you're going
to complicate your life in a way that's
going to turn into biblical proportions
of like headaches right so my advice to
guys is if you're going to invite a
woman into your life whether that's as a
girlfriend or a wife or whatever that
happens to be
you vet for red flags so that you didn't
invite a nightmare into your life i mean
you're guys i'm gonna look in the camera
and say this you're allowed to have a
pleasant fun life and you know
experience with with women like there
are good women out there still right so
vetting for the red flags is a really
really important thing to do so
back to your point of accountability
yeah there's a big problem with women
i can't remember the movie but there was
a sound bite somewhere it's on the
internet if you go look for it and it's
jack nicholson talking to woman and a
woman you know runs up to him she's like
how do you know women so well sort of
thing and he goes well
i think of a guy and then i take away
accountability and reason and then he
just turns around and walks away to get
out of the conversation now does that
mean women aren't accountable or they
don't have reason no but they're more
emotional than men and it's also why you
know
you'll see
most of like you know let's take uh
something as the fat like the fat
acceptance movement there's this there's
this movement now for
you know uh fat acceptance meaning if
you're morbidly obese and you've made
some lifestyle choices that are bad that
have created a body that's inflamed and
you're obese and your knees hurt you've
got you know underlying conditions and
stuff like that they want you to accept
that well
that's a lack of accountability and by a
wide margin
overwhelmingly this narrative is coming
from women not from men right men aren't
aren't saying you know that's body
shaming or why can't you accept me for
who i am all you gotta do is go on
social media on tick tock and it's
always morbidly obese left-leaning women
with short purple hair saying that you
know they're not different from the
skinny model that's on that's on the
billboard you know posing for
um
you know swimsuit competitions or
whatever their their things are
and that's a lack of accountability
the thing that i have faced with people
that
present that
mindset accept me for who i am and don't
acknowledge that that isn't who they are
that is their bad decisions
forming them into that
um also wants you to accept their
negative personality traits yeah they
will affect your their personality
traits their debt the three kids they
bring to the table from three guys you
know from the past that it's not their
fault you know it's it's all of those
things you know they want you to accept
a whole bunch of stuff which makes a lot
of women today for guys incredibly
difficult or even insufferable for them
to want to deal with
you know
interesting well we're both on the same
page it's it's all about accountability
and um you know if
if if you're speaking out of the
narrative you need to unplug um you know
because you're plugged into the lies of
just being good and accepting yourself
is enough then that same narrative
should in in some way apply to females
you need to unplug from the lies of just
being a good woman is enough you need to
improve your health improve your mental
health and
you know all these all these things that
encompass and there are women that will
take accountability i mean like i'm not
saying that that's not possible there
are women that do it it's just it
doesn't happen that often there's an
entire genre of
podcasts and youtube
call-in shows right now where guys try
to hold women accountable
and help them understand you know
why they get the results that they get
and i'm sure you've seen a few of them
right
i mean i don't really i don't really
dive in on what makes
a good woman
good
talking about the shows you know
specifically that are doing this like
there's a lot of views on them uh kevin
samuels is uh immediately i've seen
canvas animals
there's that there's a freshman fit
podcast so there's an entire like genre
out there of
men purporting to hold women accountable
uh and they don't
it just turns into jerry springer for
dudes it's all drama right it's like ah
yeah he got her burn like that like
that's why guys so if what they're doing
isn't
necessarily
what females really need what do you how
would you if you were to dive into which
i'm i'm pretty sure you might not but if
you decided to help women out how would
you approach it differently than these
individuals
how would i approach it i would approach
it from the perspective of a concerned
father like i would be talking to my own
daughter
you do have a daughter right yeah now
would they listen
from what i've seen on the other shows
no
it would make for good viewing though i
probably have one of the bigger channels
out there you know if i set up a
show like that because i'm real good at
that right but um you know would they
listen probably not but that's i mean
that's the way that i would encourage
you know to try to handle it from that
perspective they're not going to want to
hear be pleasant be agreeable don't you
know don't be a feminist enter his frame
compliment his life
you know don't be the focus of it don't
bring drama in his life don't bring
children from past relationships into
his life they don't like hearing stuff
like that because that means that they
have to be held accountable to certain
standards right but you know on the
other hand they want high value chad
looking guys with lots of money like
they want guys that look like you with
my kind of cash
right
that's what they want and it's like guys
that look like you with my kind of cash
what percentage of the population do you
think exists like you know all these
women that are swiping left on the
dating apps you know like the 80 of the
guys that are not attractive
right that's like most of the dudes out
there there's a very very few small like
tiny percentage of the male population
that ticks off all the boxes of women
and plus they want you to be nice and
kind and funny and competent and know
how to hang shelves and put up with
their kids and like dude like
they have this laundry list of like 300
different things right
yeah
so that's why you said last time on one
of your pockets was a six figure job it
was a couple of yeah the six sixes so
it's uh six-figure income six-pack abs
600 horsepower cars six months out of a
relationship six sensors in the pants
what's the last one i can't remember you
know
you get the idea though of course you
have to be as best as you can but also
accept them as they come and it's it's a
difficult it's a difficult equation to
really consider worth it
you